so I've been toying with this idea for a
little while now and I really want your
feedback this is really important that
the main reason we making these videos I
want your feedback below in the comments
my goal is to help reach a billion
entrepreneurs I love helping
entrepreneurs why I've started doing all
of this stuff and I get people who reach
out to me and they say Evan I want to
help I want to help you on your mission
to you I want to help contribute to your
projects or I want to help with you know
I want to help entrepreneurs with my own
project and I get people right into me
and some people will translate videos
into different languages some people
will help me find inspirational pictures
and quotes and I use them in the
promotional campaigns that we do to help
inspire entrepreneurs and I'm wondering
if it makes sense to create a home for
all of this to create a home where I can
list the projects that I'm working on
and if you want to contribute to we'd
love to have you on board or if you want
to post your own project something that
helps entrepreneurs and you need other
people that to support you because you
don't have the skills you're good at one
thing but you need other people to help
you to realize your goal I'm one
different make sense to create a form of
some kind to to house all of these ideas
the things I'm working on your projects
because the end goal here is to help
entrepreneurs it's it's hard running a
business and the more support and tools
and resources we have the better it is
the increased chance of success you'll
have and I think people want to have an
impact and give back and know that you
know the lessons that you've learned and
the skills you have are going to help
other people as well so let me know what
you think leave a comment underneath
tell me if you like the idea if you
think it's a terrible one tell me what
skills you'd like to contribute or what
project ideas you have or if you want to
help out on some of the things that I'm
working on and work with me on it let me
know leave a comment I'm going to be
watching all them that come in so please
share your feedback good or bad I really
love to hear from you and maybe we'll
launch this thing so let me know thank
you so much and I'll see you soon
you